this is figure 10 from a paper that  we'll be talking about here  um which yes is from is from the various  data and there's been a lot of  discussion about how we can't trust the  various data because just  anyone can make a claim and also it's  really hard to use it's a super clunky  system  and um really hard to navigate and um  and you know who even knows what's  hiding there is the sort of argument  um but but this is this  is what we see um in vares as reports  per million doses  um tools along uh not not very  much until the rollout of the vaccines  and suddenly  we get a a spike to support us  like this video subscribe to the channel  and consider writing a comment  and because 1984 has captured 2021 click  the link in the description to see the  full clip  on odyssey  [Music]  you